and I already had something that I love there
was already something there
hello I'm saúl el canelo álvarez and these
are
my favorite snacks
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful pulp
where from Jalisco it reminds me a lot
when I was in school like
many of my favorites
delicious
in the blame and it's not obviously
tamarind this one has like sugar chili
so it's a very delicious flavor
all combined tamarind sugar chili
[Applause]
these are half of my favorites
I think or more
about three times a  week I prepare
some with chilito lemon cucumber
so people are craving them here
we so rich also with hooks
get out of here very fat but
the hall
is
very popular the doritos in mexico are
very popular let's grab another
starbucks
the  openers are delicious
before I ate more brittons is that the
doritos are
delicious the software cites
chilito
tajín lemon that as a tough good doctor
doesn't even know the cry chilito ri  co you
make
this program that I like melt in your mouth
because the
tajín goes out with chilito
[Music]
and it gives it flavor I think that like this kind of
thing right now the fruit a lot of people do
n't like to eat fruit or on the diet  they
give them fruit and they don't like to eat
this one you put the tajín on it and I think it changes
everything now yes you're going to love it
you won't like it as a Mexican
we always have to add some
chili to the fruit on things always
we eat with
sleeve sauces it looks delicious
[Music] they
are delicious but I like the ones that
have to act and peanuts the other
elements
but I really like chocolate
in case they were with the earring
I do like this a lot
or eat on the diet for  the nights
when I get more anxiety and studying
looking for chocolates these are very,
I say the best because you can eat one
or two and it takes away your anxiety so
they save you from being able to not sleep or
sleep well
it is always very good after c  Eating
sneakers for dessert always
after eating drawing obviously I'm not on a
diet but after eating I always
see myself as one and more so when when I'm
playing golf I eat a few taquitos of
pork rinds or something like that and then I
eat a sneaker without new and fine  bread is
net quilá everything that takes care of me
today here with this walton a week without
eating I already had something that I love there
was already something there
cmr
this this
is not a lie but every day
I have boxes in my house I always have to
have three  So that I don't have to,
I always eat three or four with four
of these Nutella sticks. It's
delicious, even my daughter says
Nutella sticks again. Dad, that's how it
is
[Music
] Apart from the perfect position,
hello, I'm your friend about Canelo
Álvarez.  and thanks for being here with me
accompanying me to see my favorite snacks
and obviously I'll see you on September 17
my fight against the goal of kings
you can't miss this one
[Music]